[Música]
buenas a todos como recién me anunciaron
como recién anunciaron el caso en el
tema que me toca a mí hablar hoy esa
economía de frontera la economía de
frontera que seguramente si muchos de
ustedes viven acá en esta región lo va a
entender pero muchos de los que están
presentes no son de esta región o no
viven aquí y muchos de los que van a ver
el vídeo seguramente tampoco son de esta
región por lo tanto tenemos que explicar
un poquito qué es economía de frontera
la economía de frontera hace referencia
a esa integración formal e informal y
tal vez el fenómeno más interesante de
integración informal de un país con o de
una región con otros países
localmente nosotros nos encontramos en
una región una provincia que tiene que
es muy pequeña y tiene la característica
de tener apenas un millón doscientos mil
habitantes una provincia pequeña en
nuestro país en argentina pero en
realidad si nos comparamos a nivel
mundial también somos una economía
bastante pequeña y tenemos otra
particularidad adicional que el 90% de
nuestras
enteras son con otros países y no con
nuestro propio país con la argentina
sino que tenemos más integración más
frontera con más contacto con paraguay y
brasil que son las dos economías los dos
países que están alrededor de esta
provincia esto hace de que a pesar de
tener 12 millones de habitantes tengamos
por ejemplo si contamos solamente los
principales pasos fronterizos de la
provincia de misiones tenemos
aproximadamente 22 millones de cruces
fronterizos en esta provincia
o sea 22 veces la población que tenemos
en la provincia de misiones y esto hace
de que más allá de las exportaciones
formales o la integración formal que
tengamos con los países vecinos qué
implica la intervención de un
despachante aduana una exportación con
despachante aduanas transporte
internacional seguro y flete etcétera
etcétera
tenemos que incluir una enorme cantidad
de cuestiones que no están dentro de
esta integración formal sino es una
integración de hecho más allá de
cualquier tratado internacional más allá
de cualquier acuerdo que haya con estos
países pero a su vez también nos
encontramos con que esta situación que
nosotros creemos que es muy propia y es
muy a su vez muy poco comprendida a
nivel nacional es una situación
compartida por prácticamente en todas
las regiones del mundo hay un un país o
una serie de localidades una región de
algún país que tiene características
similares a las que tenemos nosotros
y es por eso que en realidad podemos
aprender muchísimo observando qué es lo
que sucede en otros lugares y cómo
podemos aplicarlo acá en base a cómo han
enfrentado esos desafíos
entonces la economía fronteriza es de
eso la integración formal e informal con
los países vecinos en un lugar que está
en la frontera de un país normalmente
muy alejado de las grandes ciudades
ahora cuál es el problema que tienen
estas economías fronterizas el problema
principal pasa porque desde la teoría
económica nos enseñan desde los libros
del secundario de la teoría de teoría
económica hasta en la universidad o de
economía internacional también nos
hablan de que los bienes pueden ser los
productos pueden ser divididos en
productos transables o exportables y
productos que no son exportables o no
son transables o si hay algunos
productos que se pueden comerciar con el
exterior y otros por sus características
no tienen esta posibilidad algún ejemplo
que se ve en todo el libro de texto
donde en este sentido es por ejemplo es
muy difícil para alguien que viva en una
ciudad capital de un país pensar en
viajar al exterior solamente para cenar
o para almorzar o solamente para ir
peluquería o para ir a la modista oa un
sastre para hacerse algún saco o algún
vestido
también es muy difícil pensar en ir al
exterior solamente para ir al
supermercado para comprar algún producto
que a mí me guste y volver al país de
origen y así también se encuentra en
esta misma característica los materiales
de construcción que tradicionalmente
tienen tanto volumen y tan poco valor
por peso por volumen que hace muy
difícil que sean exportados o importados
eso lo que nos dice la teoría económica
en todos los libros la mayoría de los
libros de textos que se estudian todo
eso en una economía de fronteras no es
cierto porque todo eso se puede y
sabemos los que vivimos en estas
regiones sabemos que se puede comprar y
se puede adquirir del otro lado de la
frontera y podemos pensar en un viaje al
exterior de apenas dos o tres horas y
consumir en ese periodo incluso hay
algunos casos en los cuales se van
solamente a cargar nafta por lo tanto
esto implica que la teoría económica
tradicionalmente no
no nos puede explicar cómo enfocar o
cómo focalizar está bien y generar
políticas públicas para estas regiones y
parte de esto es explicado por el hecho
de que la mayor parte de las economías
fronterizas también son periféricas o
sea están lejos de los centros urbanos
como les decía están lejos de las
ciudades capitales y por lo tanto son
realidades que no son muy tenidas en
cuenta
pero a su vez también esto hace de que
seamos tal vez las regiones más
afectadas por cualquier modificación de
tipo de cambio por cualquier
modificación de impuestos porque van a
ser distintos los impuestos o los
porcentajes las alícuotas que se cobren
de un lado o del otro de la frontera y
por cualquier modificación en la
estructura de costos que tenga una
empresa y es por eso que somos las
regiones más sensibles a las políticas
económicas a pesar de ser las menos
tenidas en cuenta porque somos las más
lejanas a los centros de decisión de
políticas económicas entonces a partir
de este diagnóstico y este problema
surge la pregunta de cómo lo enfrentamos
a este problema y cuáles son las
soluciones que podemos observar en
varios lugares del mundo y ahí tenemos
una cantidad de respuestas o ejemplos de
los cuales podemos aprender tanto en la
frontera norte con canadá o en frontera
sur con méxico de eeuu muchos casos en
latinoamerica
tenemos muchos casos en la unión europea
cuando se fue ampliando y regiones que
no eran fronteras
y empezaron a hacer frontera con alguien
que tenía otro esquema tributario otros
que más impuestos otra moneda y demás y
también algo similar en lo encontramos
en áfrica y en asia por lo tanto
ejemplos hay muchos en el mundo de los
cuales podemos aprender y para ver
cuáles son las potencialidades porque
evidentemente la el gran riesgo que
surge a partir de esto es que digamos si
nosotros tenemos un problema de
fluctuación de tipo de cambio y hoy no
es conveniente que la gente compra acá
sino que es conveniente que compre de
los otros lados de la frontera la
reacción inmediata que tiene mucha gente
es levantemos las fronteras levantemos
barreras e impidamos que la gente salga
y vaya a consumir a otros lugares y en
realidad eso nos hace como les decía hoy
muy sensible a todas estas políticas lo
cual nos convierte tal vez en el
laboratorio de competitividad o el
laboratorio donde podemos ver qué tan
buenos somos en lo que hacemos
puro que podamos encontrar en cada uno
de los países ya que no tenemos esa
barrera de la distancia física con los
otros países en los ejemplos que les
mencionaba
hoy podemos encontrar grandes grupos de
respuestas y el primero del grupo de
respuestas apunta que tenemos que
dividir la pregunta acerca de quién la
hace cuál es quién está formulando quién
está identificando el problema si el
problema es una empresa o si el problema
es la sociedad lo vemos desde la
sociedad o de una en la economía en
general si lo vemos desde el análisis
micro económico de una empresa la
respuesta es muy clara ya que el
objetivo de toda empresa es generar
rentabilidad por lo tanto pensar en una
región fronteriza o pensar en una
economía de frontera implica una enorme
potencialidad solamente en la región que
estamos que tiene 12 millones de
habitantes si pensamos solamente cuánta
población hay en los principales
principales localidades de los
principales pasos fronterizos no todos
sino los principales prácticamente
duplicamos esa población
y con un poder adquisitivo más alto al
que tenemos en la provincia de misiones
entonces fíjense que claramente en ese
sentido la adhesión desde la empresa si
consideramos un comercio por ejemplo
claramente las decisiones
que debería tomar es aprovechar esa
oportunidad ese mercado tan cercano que
tiene y tal vez en estos casos genere
sea necesario generar una inversión en
el exterior en estas localidades
fronterizas y esto es el el germen y
esto ha sido el ejemplo o el inicio por
medio del cual muchas empresas han
pegado el gran salto a nivel mundial
podemos hablar de empresas de comercio
minoristas empresas textiles tiendas de
ropa podemos hablar empresas agrícolas y
demás hay muchísimos ejemplos que
abundan en los cuales justamente esta
situación de frontera y las diferencias
sobre estos problemas económicos de tipo
de cambio y de distintos esquemas
impositivos les hizo tomar la decisión
de abrir su primer local en el exterior
y a partir de ahí tenemos una enorme
una enorme carrera de inversiones en el
exterior convirtiendo a estas empresas
en líderes en sus sectores y esto
podemos verlo en cada uno de estos de
estos ejemplos que recién les mencionaba
pero es distinta a la situación a que es
lo que puede llegar a suceder en si lo
consideramos como una sociedad si lo
consideramos como en una economía en su
conjunto de esa manera por ejemplo
tenemos que tener en cuenta que la
sociedad no busca la rentabilidad sino
lo que va a buscar la economía en su
conjunto es mantener los niveles de
actividad económica en toda la región y
esto se traduce por lo tanto en mantener
la cantidad de empleo que hay en toda la
región o tener más y mejor y en empleo y
de mayor calidad o sea con mejores
remuneraciones mejores mejor cobertura
social y demás esto qué significa que
tenemos que pensar en todo el conjunto
de la sociedad y no solamente en la
situación concreta de una empresa en
particular
en este en esta línea es interesante
pensar que podemos también dividir en
dos grandes grupos a los distintos los
distintos enfoques con los cuales
podemos abordar esta realidad por un
lado podemos pensar que cada una de las
industrias sectores económicos pueden
ser reflejas de la actividad económica
en su conjunto o pueden ser impulsoras
de esta actividad qué significa esto que
son dos términos tablets un poco
complejos las actividades reflejas son
las que simplemente reaccionan ante los
recursos ya disponibles localmente
implican más movimiento económico un
ejemplo de esto es un empleado público
un empleado de la municipalidad o de
cualquier ente ente público cualquier
persona que tenga un salario en esta
localidad va y gasta su sueldo en un
supermercado en un quiosco en una
librería una concesionaria automóviles
etcétera
esas son actividades que reflejan
simplemente la actividad económica que
ya está
localizada si nosotros nos concentramos
solamente en ese enfoque si nosotros nos
concentramos solamente en esa forma de
ver la realidad la solución ante estos
problemas económicos pasan simplemente
por dos posibilidades pasan por levantar
barreras que impidan que nuestros
consumidores locales salgan y vayan a
consumir a otros lugares o pasa por
reducir la estructura de costos que
tienen en estas estas empresas implica
menores impuestos lo cual de alguna
forma de financiar ya del sistema
público municipal provincial o nacional
o sub nacional según cada país como se
ha analizado
y por lo tanto tendría otros efectos no
tan positivos y terminaría siendo un
juego de suma cero donde cada uno
estaríamos peleando entre nosotros
simplemente para distribuir nos la torta
que hoy ya existe de riqueza económica
en la región otra forma distinta de
pensar el problema es pensar en
convertir a cada uno de estos sectores
en actividades impulsores de la
actividad económica qué significa esto
implica pensar en que cada una de estas
actividades cualquiera de ellas puede
traer recursos desde el exterior hasta
hacia esta región y de esa forma generar
más actividad económica hacer crecer la
torta de la riqueza económica local
emplear a más gente con mejores sueldos
qué significa esto
esto significa pensar en que por ejemplo
los comerciantes se transformen y se hay
orden no solamente pensando en la
competencia del otro lado de la frontera
sino pensar más en el mediano y largo
plazo y es por eso que insisto en esta
idea del laboratorio de competitividad
que se conformamos naturalmente porque
es el lugar apropiado para pensar
políticas a mediano y a largo plazo
esto implica pensar no solamente una
cuestión impositiva implica esto
obviamente está incluido pero no
solamente implica pensar eso sino
implica también pensar por ejemplo
cuáles son las grandes tendencias que
afectan al comercio mundial y dentro de
esto nos vamos a ver obligados a
incorporar el análisis el hecho de que
según las proyecciones que hay en los
próximos 10 a 20 años aproximadamente el
70% del empleo del comercio va a
desaparecer por va a ser reemplazado por
procesos automatizados eso implique
implica que las empresas locales se
tienen que adornar o se tienen que
ajustar y adaptar esa nueva tecnología
para poder crecer y para poder generar
trabajo de esa manera
adelantándose a esta ola que está
viniendo no es casualidad que en nuestro
país la principal empresa o la empresa
de mayor valor de mercado que existe no
produce combustibles no produce petróleo
no produce automóviles ni es una
industria sino es un canal de
comercialización
electrónico que es muy conocido por
todos ustedes eso hace ese es el gran
desafío que tiene hoy el comercio
si hablamos de industria seriamente
tendremos que pensar en radicación de
nuevas inversiones desde el exterior
hacia aquí y eso implica
hablar de infraestructura hablar de
conectividad hablar de energía hablar de
innovación de productos y de procesos
principalmente no solamente de productos
sino casi siempre se habla más de
procesos que de productos y finalmente
también implica trabajar en clusters que
es una charla que pueda que sería un
poco más larga de dedicarme a esto pero
implica trabajar en todos estos estos
temas que implica llegar a generar la
llegada de inversiones del exterior para
justamente generar exportaciones
formales que ingresen más divisas a la
región y de esa forma hacer crecer la
torta desde el lado turismo también
implica pensarlo la forma
estas mismas cuestiones de forma
distinta y hay muchos casos en los
ejemplos que les mencionaba
anteriormente hay muchos casos exitosos
algunos muy cercanos a esta localidad
donde vemos que esa localidad que
veíamos como competencia desleal porque
tenía menores impuestos tenían menores
salarios y se veía que competía con la
economía local a ciertos sumado como un
nuevo atractivo turístico en la región
donde le decimos al turista
internacional que vengo al turista de
otros lugares del país que venga se
pueden quedar un día más a la gente acá
y nosotros los llevamos a hacer compras
del otro lado de la frontera nos
acercamos y de esa forma también se
puede puede generar esa innovación en
cómo pensar nuevamente el turismo esto
implica por supuesto también agilización
de los trámites fronterizos implica
innovación de productos e inversión por
supuesto también en distintas ofertas
para esa turista que se va a quedar más
tiempo porque obviamente no va a estar
las 24 horas comprando sino que va a
tener hacer una enorme cantidad de cosas
también y tenemos que darle oferta para
esto pero todo esto implica pensar
situación de frontera no como una un
problema no como una dificultad sino
principalmente como una enorme
potencialidad que tenemos nosotros
estamos acostumbrados
tradicionalmente se ve a la región
fronteriza como una región con muchos
problemas económicos muy difícil de
trabajar donde tenemos más problemas y
difícil difícil dificultad para competir
con los vecinos pero en realidad lo que
tenemos es una enorme oportunidad para
pensar la competitividad a largo plazo
tenemos dos grandes opciones tenemos la
opción de construir barreras para aislar
aislarnos del mundo o tenemos la la
enorme oportunidad de aprovechar esa
integración esa cercanía cultural que
tenemos para iniciar la
internacionalización y la inversión de
nuestras empresas y de esa forma atraer
más recursos a la región muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]